[Applause]  especially with a white jersey on so now  the pacers get another opportunity as a  missed shot here  and they continue to extend it jazz  can't recover quick enough  that can not happen  jazz turn it over brogden three  rudy right on top of the rim so no harm  done  on that giveaway oh donald looked like  he was holding that knee  oh no he's been such a  durable player  and he falls into the arms of royce  hold your breath didn't see the play but  man you just hate to see that  thorough on such a day of celebration  with  dwyane wade joining the ownership ranks  of the jazz and now you're watching your  star player be helped off the floor  i don't know if i want to look at this  video man it's tough  hopefully is it's not as bad as  maybe the video we can't really get a  look but it looks like that  right foot  [Music]  was caught as he was going down and he  grabbed ford  immediately